THE PRESIDENT'S RELAUNCH IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
TOMORROW NIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS FORMALLY LAUNCHING HIS
REELECTION CAMPAIGN IN ORLANDO,
FLORIDA.
AND AS I SAID, THE CROWD IS
ALREADY LINING UP 40 HOURS
EARLY.
BUT THE USUAL SUSPECTS IN THE
MEDIA WERE FALLING ALL OVER
THEMSELVES TO PREEMOTION --
RAIN ON THE RALLY.
THEY THINK THE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ABC NEWS INTERVIEW WITH
STEPHANOPOULOS GAVE HIM THEIR
OPENING.
>> HE ABDICATED HIS OATH OF
OFFICE.
HE DID IT THE OTHER DAY ON
STEPHANOPOULOS'S INTERVIEW.
HE IS NOT PROTECTING THE
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE IS NOT COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING OUR ELECTION
INTEGRITY AND SECURITY.
>> Laura: YES, HE IS.
AS WE EXPLAINED LAST WEEK IN
THE ANGLE THAT ARGUMENT IS
ABSURD.
NOW, IN FACT, IN MANY CRITICAL
AREAS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS TAKEN A TOUGHER STANCE
AGAINST RUSSIA THAN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE.
WE'VE DOCUMENTED THAT SHOW
AFTER SHOW.
BUT NONE OF THAT MATTERS WHEN
THE REPORTER ASKING THE
QUESTIONS HAS AN AGENDA, EVEN
IF HE IS AIMABLE IN THE PROCESS.
THE AGENDA NAMELY TO
RESUSCITATE AND REVISIT THE
MUELLER REPORT.
AND EVEN BY THE WAY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT EXPRESSES MINOR ANOW
ANSWER NOT RELATED TO RUSSIA OR
MUELLER THEY TRY TO MAKE HIM
OUT TO BE THE BAD GUY.
>> President Trump: IT'S A
FANTASTIC FINANCIAL STATEMENT.
IT IS A FANTASTIC FINANCIAL
STATEMENT AND LET'S DO THAT
OVER.
HE IS COUGHING IN THE MIDDLE OF
MY ANSWER.
I DON'T LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW?
IF YOU'RE GOING TO COUGH,
PLEASE LEAVE THE ROOM.
YOU WANT TO DO THAT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY THERE?
>> WE CHANGED THE ANGLE.
>> AT SOME POINT -- AT SOME
POINT I LOOK FORWARD TO FRANKLY
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE PEOPLE SEE
MY FINANCIAL STATEMENT.
>> Laura: EVERYONE WHO DOES TV
KNOWS THEY'RE HONEST THAT THAT
WAS LOUSY FORM FOR
STEPHANOPOULOS NOT TO STOP THE
CAMERAS FROM ROLLING AND AIR
THAT ENTIRE EXCHANGE BUT HEY,
ANYTHING TO ADVANCE THE TRUMP'S
MEAN NARRATIVE.
THE LAST PART IS TELLING WHERE
HE DOES THE -- AND SO HE IS
JUST WRONGED IN SOME MEANINGFUL
WAY BY HIS CHIEF OF STAFF
COUGHING.
>> Laura: OR MAYBE IT WAS ALL A
PLOT.
>> ONE THEORY I READ, GIVEN THE
SUBJECT AND THE SENSITIVITY
SURROUNDING HIS TAX RETURNS
SOMEBODY POINTED OUT MAYBE IT
WAS MICK MULVANEY TRYING TO
SAVE THE PRESIDENT AND NOT
TRYING TO CREATE A SOUND BITE
THAT COULD BE USED LATER ON FOR
ABC.
>> Laura: COUGH GATE.
MORE GOOFYNESS.
HOW MANY TIMES IF I SAID THAT
TO RAYMOND, STOP COUGHING?
WE WERE HOWLING WHEN IT
HAPPENED.
LET'S GET SERIOUS.
TOMORROW IN ORLANDO THE
PRESIDENT HAS A CHANCE TO
RELAUNCH THIS CAMPAIGN AND JUST
HIT EVERY NOTE.
I THINK PART OF IT IS SHRUGGING
OFF THE INCLINATION TO
RELITIGATE EVERY PAST ISSUE,
INSULT, TWEET, INVESTIGATION.
AND THE BEST WAY TO FRAME ALL
OF THIS IS LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH EVEN
WITH TWO YEARS OF THE RUSSIA
HOAX.
>> YOU'VE GOT THE STOCK MARKET
FLIRTING WITH RECORD HIGHS, THE
NEAR RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> GDP GROWTH CONTINUING AT
BETTER THAN EXPECTED RATES.
>> UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
450,000 MANUFACTURING JOBS HAVE
BEEN ADDED.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE LOWEST
IT'S BEEN HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES SINCE 1969.
JOB GROWTH IS STRONG, HOURLY
WAGES ARE UP.
>> Laura: THAT SHOULD BE THE
PLAY LIST FOR TRUMP 2020.
IF ANY OTHER PRESIDENT WERE
DOING THE THINGS TRUMP IS DOING
FOR THIS ECONOMY, FOR JOBS, FOR
WORKERS, TAKING ON CHINA MOST
OF THE MEDIA WOULD BE THROWING
ROSE PET ALLS AND PARADE.
WHO ELSE HAS WORKED MORE
DILIGENTLY TO --
>> President Trump: WE'RE
FORCING COMPETITION AND DRIVING
DOWN COSTS, THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE GETTING THE DRUG
PRICES STOPPING FROM THOSE
TREMENDOUS INCREASES THAT HAVE
TAKEN EFFECT FOR SO MANY YEARS
FOR SO MANY DECADES THEY'VE
BEEN GOING ONE DIRECTION, UP.
>> Laura: WHO ELSE HAS CUT
REGULATIONS LIKE THIS PRESIDENT
HAS TO UNBURDEN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES?
WHO ELSE HAS RECOGNIZED AND
RESPONDED TO THE CRISIS AT THE
BORDER LIKE TRUMP?
USING A THREAT OF TERRORISTS
AND DIPLOMATIC PRESSURE TRUMP
HAS GOTTEN MEXICO TO STEP UP
FINALLY ON THEIR IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW
IMMIGRATION DEAL WITH MEXICO
STARTING TO SHOW AN IMPACT.
6,000 MEXICAN SOLDIERS DEPLOYED
ALONG THE COUNTRY'S SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH GUATEMALA.
STOPPING SOME CARAVANS AND
PEOPLE ON RAFTS AND 800
MIGRANTS STOPPED NEAR THE TEXAS
BORDER OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> Laura: BUT FOR TRUMP THEY
ALL WOULD HAVE SURELY MADE IT
TO THE U.S. BORDER AND WHO ELSE
HAS STOOD UP TO THE CHINESE ON
THE WORLD STAGE?
TO END THE ONGOING BEIJING
ORCHESTRATED RIP-OFF OF
AMERICAN INDUSTRY AND INTECH
TAOU ALL PROPERTY.
ONLY TRUMP.
I HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
TAX REFORM.
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA.
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS.
THE ONLY RESPONSE FROM
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IS RUSSIA, IDENTITY
POLITICS, DEMONIZING WEALTH
CREATORS AND OF COURSE THE
GO-TO WE'LL GIVE YOU FREE STUFF.
>> EVERY AMERICAN REGARDLESS OF
HIS OR HER INCOME IS ENTITLED
TO THE RIGHT TO A DECENT JOB
THAT PAYS A LIVING WAGE.
>> TECHNICAL SCHOOL, TWO-YEAR
COLLEGE, FOUR-YEAR PUBLIC
COLLEGE ALL FREE AND
TUITION-FREE FOR ALL OF OUR
KIDS.
>> I THINK THAT ANYONE WHO IS
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE
IN NEED OF HEALTHCARE,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED, WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO SEE THEY
ARE CARED FOR.
>> Laura: THEY LEAVE OUT THE
PART WHERE YOU'LL PAY THROUGH
THE NOSE FOR ALL OF THIS.
WHILE THE GOVERNMENT MAKES MORE
DECISIONS FOR YOU, YOUR FAMILY,
AND YOUR BUSINESS.
THAT MEANS LESS FREEDOM.
WELL, TRUMP NEEDS TO REMIND
AMERICA IF THEY SEND BERNIE,
ELIZABETH OR UNCLE JOE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE THE DEMOCRAT
SOCIALISTS WILL RUN OUT OF
OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY AND WHAT
HAPPENS THEN?
THE COUNTRY'S ECONOMY WILL
CRUMBLE INTO AN ABYSS OF
MEDIOCRITY.
>> NO, GOD, PLEASE, NO, NO, NO!
NO!
>> Laura: THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE THE TRUMP
REELECTION MESSAGE SHOULD BE
SIMPLE, DO YOU WANT TO KEEP THE
GOOD TIMES GOING AND MAKE
AMERICA EVEN STRONGER?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU
WERE IN JANUARY 2017?
SOME OF YOU MAY NOT LIKE SOME
OF TRUMP'S TWEETS.